A NUMBER OF TEAMS REPORTED
POSITIVE TESTS FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THE CRITICISM THE CONDEMNATION
OF PREMISED OR NARENDRA MODI
AND HIS GOVERNMENT'S FAILED
RESPONSE CONTINUES TO GO
LOUDER.
OPPOSITION LEADER TWEETED THAT
THEY ARE GOVERNMENT, ACTIVELY
HELPED THE VIRUS REACHED THE
STAGE WHERE THERE'S NO THE WAY
TO STOP IT.
ADDING A CRIME HAS BEEN
COMMITTED AGAINST INDIA.
HE MAY BE RIGHT, IN TERMS OF
HELPING SPREAD THE VIRUS.
NARENDRA MODI CONTINUES TO HOLD
A BIG POLITICAL RALLIES,
MASSIVE GATHERING HAVE MOSTLY
MASSIVE CROWDS OF MASKED
SUPPORTERS WHICH ARE BEING
PROVEN TO BE SUPERSPREADER OF.
AND CNN'S CLOSED-DOOR BEGINS
OUR COVERAGE >> AS A RAGING
PANDEMIC TORE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, 2000 FLOCK TO THE
STREET FOR POLITICAL RALLIES
WITH HARDLY A MASK INSIGHT AT
ONE GATHERING, INDIA'S'S PRIME
MINISTER, NARENDRA MODI,
PRAISED THE TURNOUT.
" I'VE NEVER SEEN SUCH A HUGE
CROWDS LATERALLY " THE SAME DAY,
MORE THAN 260,000 CASES OF
COVID WERE RECORDED IN INDIA.
SHORTLY AFTER, MILLIONS OF
WORSHIPPERS WERE ALLOWED TO
CONGREGATE FOR THE END OF THE
WEEKLONG HINDU KUMBH MELA
PILGRIMAGE.
AFTER ALL, WHAT HE HAD ALREADY
DECLARED VICTORY AGAINST COVID.
>> IN A COUNTRY WHERE 80% OF
THE WORLD POPULATION LIVE, WE
HAVE [INAUDIBLE]
A MAJOR TRAGEDY BY EFFECTIVELY
[INAUDIBLE]
WE HAVE SAVED MANKIND FROM A
BIG DISASTER BY SAVING OUR
CITIZENS FROM THE PANDEMIC.
>> AS A 2ND WAVE OF CORONAVIRUS
RAVAGES THIS COUNTRY, IN THOSE
WORDS HAVE COME BACK TO HAUNT
MODI.
CRITICS ACCUSE HIM OF PUTTING
HIS POLITICAL INTERESTS AHEAD
OF THE HEALTH OF THE NATION.
>> WE DIDN'T EVEN ASK THE
QUESTION OF WHAT WE NEEDED TO
DO, THEY SIT ON LEARNING FROM
THIS LAST YEAR, IN THE EVENT
THAT WE HAVE A 2ND WAVE, A 2ND
WAVE WAS NEVER OFF THE TABLE.
YOU JUST HAVE TO LOOK AROUND
THE WORLD.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE SCIENTIST
TO SEE THAT.
WE DID NOTHING.
INSTEAD, WE CELEBRATED A BIT TO
PREMATURELY, INDIAN
EXCEPTIONALISM.
>> NOW INDIA'S HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM IS ON THE BRINK OF
COLLAPSE.
SHORTAGES OF EVERYTHING FROM
DOCTORS AND DRUGS TO BEDS AND
OXYGEN.
AFTER YEARS OF NEGLECT.
IT WAS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT TO CONTAIN THE SPREAD
OF COVID HERE IN INDIA.
THIS IS A DENSELY POPULATED
COUNTRY OF NEARLY 1. 4 BILLION
PEOPLE.
THE INDIAN GOVERNMENT IS
BLAMING THE RAPID SPREAD ON
THIS NEW DOUBLE MUTANT VARIANT,
AND IT SAYS THAT IT WARNED
STATES TO REMAIN VIGILANT.
STILL, MANY DOCTORS AGREE THAT
THE DEVASTATING TOLL OF THIS
2ND WAVE COULD HAVE BEEN
MITIGATED, WITH BETTER
PREPARATIONS AND A COORDINATED
RESPONSE.
ASSURED OF VICTORY AGAINST THE
VIRUS, INDIA BEGAN EXPORTING IN
THE VACCINES IT WAS PRODUCING.
.
INSTEAD OF INOCULATING ITS OWN
POPULATION.
HOW MUCH RESPONSIBILITY DOES
PRIME MINISTER MODI BARE FOR
THIS?
>> HE HAS THE PRIME MINISTER OF
THE COUNTRY.
HE TAKES FULL RESPONSIBILITY
FOR ALL THAT WE DO GOOD AND ALL
THAT GOES WRONG.
>> DO YOU THINK THIS WILL HAVE
AN IMPACT ON HIS POPULARITY?
>> I THINK AS OF NOW WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN ESPECIALLY OVER THE
LAST 3 WEEKS, IS COMPLETE
POLICY ABDICATION, AND
CERTAINLY, I HOPE, THAT WE HOLD
OUR GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WHAT WE ARE SEEING TODAY.
>> THE GOVERNMENT HAS ANNOUNCED
A RAFT OF MEASURES, WOLF, TO
COMBAT THIS CRISIS, INCLUDING
GETTING THE NAVY AND THE AIR
FORCE INVOLVED.
IT'S NOT REALLY CLEAR YET WHAT,
IF ANY POLITICAL FALLOUT THERE
WILL BE FOR PRIME MINISTER
MODI.
BUT ONE THING IS CLEAR -- THIS
PROBLEM IS NOT GOING AWAY.
ONE STATE HEALTH MINISTER ARE
WARNING THAT A 3RD WAVE COULD
BE ON THE HORIZON.